trey second turnover the early going
[Applause]
washington looking for hayward catch and
shoot corner three nothing but net
trey moves in and leaves that one short
this is the charlotte running game that
kelly was talking about
as gordon hayward he's got collins in
tight and he missed it
and john goes down hard and boy i
thought he might have been
tangled up there with ball for an
instant now a no look to the corner and
hayward's three that's good
[Applause]
[Music]
the fast he throw that like a hundred
miles right at his chin
hayward and one did you see the
the beanie right there man point he
didn't see that coming
but it's the zone defense i think that's
confusing hawks
hawks show zone of their own biz to the
cutting hayward
and they got right to the middle of that
zone with a slash from the top closing
into the halfway mark of our second
quarter
devante grant back in for the hornets
along with terry rozier
and pj washington two more for hayward
50 35 hayward left alone
splash he cannot do that one
in the first half just not happening
from deep hawks three of 16 on threes
graham
oh stolen back by hayward he lays it in
23 for gordon hayward
[Applause]
[Music]
cam loses it going up loose ball
charlotte graham lob hayward dunk
backs up to create some space biambo
screens for him and
gordo gets into the lane little step
back boy he's on it tonight
64-49
hayward creates a little space that
little drive of the shoulder
just enough to get hunter out of the way
that's the thing a scorer can do boyd
pierce is going to stick with this group
and why not these guys have gotten the
hawks back in it
back door cutting hayward for the jam
well drawn play by borrego and company
coming out of the timeout
on kevin or two team fouls i should say
on atlanta
hayward from the foul line swish
hayward starts to go up
banks it missed it got his own miss
follows and hits and a foul on atlanta
together like charlotte
what a luxury now to have a guy like
hayward in a
battle like this a close game a guy
who's been through the war
good man tough
tough shot 43 for hayward
[Applause]
97-90